ici les costumes d'Halloween côtoie les
manteaux d'hiver ça ça va disparaître
bientôt
pour être remplacé par les vêtements
d'hiver avec le temps froid qui
s'installe la Société
Saint-Vincent-de-Paul de Montréal entre
dans l'une des périodes les plus
achalandées de l'année on voit une
augmentation de 20 à 30% de plus de
ventes depuis un an de nouveau client
viennent dans cette friperie avec la
hausse du coût de la vie certains
tentent d'économiser comme ils le
peuvent c'est sûr que avant c'était mal
vu mais maintenant c'est presque à la
mode à la mode en raison du taux
d'inflation l'indice des prix à la
consommation a atteint un sommet en 40
ans cet été avant de connaître un léger
recul et s'est établi à 6,9% au mois de
septembre toujours bien au-delà de la
cible de la Banque du Canada on sait
très bien que c'est des mauvaises
nouvelles pour les familles aujourd'hui
le coût coût de la ville
d'épicerie
les coûts sont en train d'augmenter à un
moment où les gens sont vraiment
inquiets
c'est effectivement l'épicerie surtout
qui gonfle l'inflation par rapport à la
même période l'an dernier le prix de la
viande a augmenté de 7,6%. celui des
produits laitiers de 9,7%, la
boulangerie de 14,8 % tandis que les
légumes frais coûtent 11,8 % plus cher
en moyenne donc le prix des aliments a
bondit de 11,4% en septembre du jamais
vu depuis 1981 maintenant est-ce que
c'est quelque chose qui va qui va durer
ou pas c'est les prix des aliments sont
souvent en fonction des conditions
climatiques dans les endroits où les
aliments sont produits d'ici à ce
qu'elle soit plus abordable les denrées
à la banque alimentaire de la Société
Saint-Vincent de Paul continueront de
s'envoler rapidement tout comme les
vêtements et les autres produits dans le
magasin adjacent on parle justement d'un
mobilier qu'on va avoir au lieu de le
payer peut-être
10002500 dollars nous on va le vendre
peut-être à 200$
une sorte de refuge à l'abri des
turbulences économiques ici Sébastien
Desrosiers Radio-Canada Montréal